hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast whole transcriptome in
situ
cells atlas reveals cellular composition
and interactions in the developing human
brain i'm susie valdez of lab roots and
i'll be your moderator for today's
event today's educational web seminar is
brought to you by
lab roots and sponsored by illumina and
nano string technologies
for more information about our sponsors
please visit their website
at illumina.com and nanostring.com
so let's get started i'd like to remind
everyone that this event
is interactive and we encourage you to
participate
by submitting as many questions as you
want at any time you want during the
presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box
and click the send button if you have
any trouble hearing or seeing this
presentation
click on the support tab at the top
right of your presentation window
or report your problem by clicking on
the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
i'd now like to introduce our presenters
dr omar byrokhtar dr powell
zajac and dr rudy van isten for complete
biography of our presenters
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen
dr van heisen you may now begin your
presentation
welcome sir thank you for the
introduction
um so i'll just take a couple of minutes
not too much of the time
to take away from the scientific talk
from omar
my plan is just to give you a brief
introduction on the technology
that has been used there so it's an
introduction into geomix digital spatial
profiling
so let me first tell you a little bit
about nanostring nanostring was founded
in 2003
it has its headquarters in seattle and
it came out of the lab of systems
biology from leroy hood
and over the years we focused on
biomarker discovery
and translational research providing
tools to do all that
so the first tool that came out was in
2008 the encounter analysis system
mainly used for gene expression
biomarker development
measuring up to 800 targets per sample
in one go
and now since last year we've launched
our geomex digital spatial profiler
which is very exciting um
just a little bit as an introduction on
the end counter system and the
applications and panels so the encounter
system
is a it's a technology that uses digital
barcodes like like you can see here
fluorescent molecules in a stretch in a
row
and they serve the purpose as a real
barcode
identifying targets of interest that you
would like to measure
it's an in-solution hybridization where
we hybridize probes
holding these molecular barcodes
they hybridize to the rna of interest
when once you have extracted the rna
from your
from your tissue cells ffpe block
whatever material that you might be
working with
in the end we will count the number of
these barcodes getting
digital counts for every target of
interest in your sample
so we really count the number of
molecules without any enzymes
without any amplification so that was
the first system
that has been used a lot that is still
used today
for which we have off-the-shelf panels
available for oncology research
immunology research
and neuroscience for bulk gene
expression analysis
besides gene expression you can also
measure microrna expression or express
fusion deeds
so this has been used a lot and there
are many publications out there that
have used this technology to find
biomarkers
to for instance predict response to
treatment
however there is a problem there and
sometimes
with bulk analysis extracting rna from
tissue so-called grind and bind assay
sometimes it can be difficult to find
the correct biomarkers
to to do these kind of predictions
very often because sometimes
tissues are very heterogeneous and doing
the grind and bind assay
the differences that are there in that
tissue somewhere
they're simply diluted out by the grind
and by nature of this assay
so by doing this people have a need for
spatial analysis
to be able to identify where the targets
are
in the tissue and what the expression
levels are
but biomarkers are simply not only one
or two targets
mostly they're comprised about many
different targets at the same time
so it's always a trade-off in terms of
plexing in terms of
cutting spatial or non-spatial
resolution also on quantitation and
precision
so that trade-off can be a pain and
sometimes
people just give in on getting the
spatial information because they simply
need
more plexi a solution for this
is the geomex digital spatial profiler
and it has already
shown its value so it's only launched
last year in march
but as of today and this slide is
already old actually because it says
21 peer reviewed publications to date i
checked it this morning and is actually
25 already
and this is very unique for such a young
technology that has just recently been
introduced
so the way it works is we have a
collection
of antibodies or a collection of
nc2 hybridization probes that are
labeled with a fluorescent molecule
so it's very similar to immunostic
chemistry or in c2 hybridization
so we call those imaging reagents but on
top of that we also have
profiling reagents that we also bind
onto the ffbe tissue
which you cannot see by the fluorescent
molecule
but they are tagged with a dna tag
like you can see here a dna attack on an
antibody
or a dna tag on an nc2 hybridization
probe
they're bound to that probe or antibody
with a photo cleavable linker
so that when we shine uv light they will
be cleaved off
and they will be submerged in the buffer
that is on top of the slide
so that's actually the process we first
stain the slide with
these morphology visualization markers
together with offending reagents so
these are
many more probes or antibodies targeting
the other targets of interest
using the morphology markers we get the
morphology of the tissue
allowing us to really pinpoint regions
of interest
in that tissue where we would like to
focus on to measure the abundance levels
of the other
protein or rna targets what our whatever
application that we're running at the
moment
from that morphology and the region of
interest that we select
we can very specifically shine uv light
within those regions of interest causing
the dna tags to cleave off
then we go in with a little stripper
tool that hovers just above
that region of interest and we suck up
these dna tags and deposit them in the
collection plate inside the instrument
that collection plate is then taken and
which forms
like a surrogate representation of the
abundance levels of all the
targets within those regions of interest
then we either
measure the abundance levels through the
digital encounter technology
or like has been done in this situation
that you're going to hear about later
using illumina sequencers to do the
counting of these barcodes
thereby counting number of targets in
the regions of interest on the tissue so
we'll get digital counts
in the end these raw data files are then
imported back
into the instrument which will connect
back this count information
to the specific regions of interest in
the tissue
so coupling back the spatial information
an extra additional thing that we can do
because we have a very sensitive
digital micro mirror device holding one
million individual micro mirrors
we can shape the uv light in a way that
it forms for instance
a mask corresponding to the expression
level
of the morphology markers that you're
using
in this slide you see that we have
stained
a section with pancetta keratin in
yellow and there is a dna marker in
pink and you can put a mask
indicating the pancita keratin so mainly
100
tumor we could can put a mask on that
and that's what you see in the top right
everything that's white is 100 tumor so
we can first
shine the light on everything that's 100
tumor using that mask
now we could actually also take the
inverse of that and focus
shine the light only on the tumor micro
environment
so this will be two separate collections
from the same well
profiling the abundance levels of the
targets within the tumor area and the
tumor microenvironment area
using that digital micro mirror device
we can do many different types
of masking so you can just do geometric
shapes
where you just shine the light on a
geometric shape that you draw
on the tissue you can do the
segmentation like i just explained
you can even do it more specifically
focus on specific cell populations
identified by specific markers that
identify
cell populations and then shine the
light on all of the cells that meet that
criterium
within the region of interest that you
have drawn
a fourth one that you could do is you
can do contour profiling where you have
for instance in this example here you
have a line of macrophages
that are infiltrating towards the tumor
so then you can sort of profile only
that line of macrophages
but also have bands going further out or
further inside from the tumor
to learn more about the changes and
expression of the targets of interest
going further out or further in from
that line of macrophages as a baseline
and the loss alternate that you can do
you can just put a whole grit
on top of the tissue and treat every
square within that grit as a separate
region of interest
just to learn more about the differences
in spatial expression throughout the
whole tissue
with the geomics digital spatial
profiler you can do this
with protein panels targeting up to 96
different proteins
in the field of immune oncology on the
left
and in the field of neuroscience we
always run a core
of 20 main main targets
and then you can spike in different
modules of interest which are depicted
here on this slide in grey
all of the specific content can be found
on our website
most interestingly at the moment is
the cancer transcriptomic class this is
an rna panel
where we have ropes targeting the rna
and in this situation we cover more than
1800 genes
mainly in the field of immune oncology
covering
55 specific pathways related to tumor
biology
immune response microenvironment and so
on
so this is ideal to do uh
research and find predictive biomarkers
um in a tumor scientific setting
so this is already available now so
people who have a system can run this
what we're working on and what we're
going to launch in 2021 is the whole
transcriptoma
s covering over 18 000 genes
and this actually really also allows you
to do even pathway analysis
so not available yet will be available
through our technology access program
end of the year
and we'll officially launch that next
year
doing the readout for these bigger
panels you need to do this on illumina
sequencers
that's the way it has been designed you
see here a number of
these sequencing instruments so most of
them
will be run on a nexseek
or on a novasiq so that's the way that
this is going to work
and the next presenter will
explain you a little bit more about
these instruments before we go to the
scientific talk
thank you for your attention over to you
paul
all right so thank you so much all of
you for joining us at this
webinar and the spatial biology is a
really exciting
area because it allows you to dig deeper
into your your tissues and get the
increased understanding of what is going
on the processes that are going on
and my name is pavel sayak and i'm part
of illumina's marketing team
and i have the great pleasure in the
next couple of minutes to
tell you a little bit about our company
what we do
and how illumina sequencing is an
integral part
of the spatial biology workflow
and first i wanted to start with a brief
brief introduction of
illumina so for those of you who are not
familiar with our company
we are a global company and we develop
manufacture and market
innovative next generation sequencing
and microarray technologies
and our technology enables you to make
foundational discoveries
to learn more about biology but also to
transform
medicine and ultimately to impact lives
and to date our technology has been used
in more than 200 000 publications
so really showing that this is a robust
technology giving you results that you
can trust
and you can get access to the technology
in one of two ways
either you can purchase a sequencing
system a sequencing solution
and implement it in your own lab but you
can also gain access to the technology
through a
service provider and there are multiple
service providers found
throughout europe
and our systems and our solutions enable
a wide range of
spatial sequencing applications so
no matter what is the size of your
spatial project whether you have a
single sample or many samples
whether you want to profile these
samples to a high depth or a low depth
we do have a sequencing solution that
fits your output
needs so we have on the
left side the iseq 100 system
a small benchtop system giving you 4
million sequencing reads
all the way up to the novaseq 6000
system that you can see on the right
hand side
that gives 20 billion reads and recently
we also launched the nexi
2000 system which allows deeper larger
studies but still within a
benchtop package
and the sequencing is a single
technology but it
unlocks a wide range of applications
so the sequencer can be thought of as as
a tool
that can be used for many different
methods for many different things
so as is exemplified in this webinar
the sequencing can be used to read out
digital spatial
profiling assays but in the field of
neuroscience for instance it can also be
used to study variants
for instance via genome sequencing or
exome sequencing
or it can be used to assess different
regulatory features such as chromatin
accessibility
so with a single technology single
sequencing platform
you can unlock a wide range of
applications
and illumina has a long-standing
tradition of technological innovation
technological advances
so in our nexic 2000 system
that was launched earlier this year we
have incorporated more than 75
key technology innovations and these
translate into number of advantages
so for instance the there is a reduction
in operating cost and an increase in
output
if you compare the nexiq 2000 system
with the nexiq
500 and 550 systems so allowing you to
do
larger studies
and recently we also introduced a new
version of the consumables kit for our
nova seq 6000 system so that's our
production scale
sequencer and these consumables have a
number of benefits
for instance the shelf life has been
increased and
and and they come at a very
cost attractive price
this means that you can now sequence
more
with the same budget so this unlocks the
door
for wider deeper and larger
studies and if you're interested in
hearing more about the different
products and solutions that we offer
or you want to discuss the sequencing
requirements for your study for your
project
we are always happy to help so please
don't hesitate
to get in touch
and i wanted to thank you very much for
your attention and for joining this
webinar
and before i end the presentation over
to
dr omer byrakta the star of the show
we have two quick questions for you
and the first question is are you
planning to run a spatial biology
research project
in the future
and now over to the second question
so how do you access next generation
sequencing
excellent so thank you so much for
answering the questions
and now i will hand the presentation
over to dr orman byrector
please take it away
thank you paul and rudy so it's a
pleasure to join all of you here today
across this webinar uh
many thanks to illumina and nana's
strength for the invite to showcase our
science here
um so i'll jump right to it uh
you know my name is omar bairakhtar i'm
a group leader at the welcome sanger
institute in the uk
our lab is interested in studying cell
type diversity
in the human brain and today i'll tell
you about how we've been using the
newest
nanostring whole transcriptome profiling
technologies
to study the cellular architecture of
this wonderful tissue
so as i said you know the questions in
our lab are
research questions are geared on
understanding cell type diversity
in both health and disease as many of
you might know
in both the developing and the adult
human brain there's an
astonishing diversity of different cell
types most
people will be familiar with the fact
that neurons are an extremely diverse
set of cells
in terms of their functions their
electrophysiological properties
shapes and molecular profiles in
addition to neurons there's also a vast
array of
non-neuronal cells in the brain that are
really important for neuronal function
these include astrocytes
oligodendrocytes and microglia
so uh after years of neuroscience what
we know is that
for normal brain function all of these
cell types need to be performing
really different tasks and they need to
do this in a coordinated manner within
each other
and on top of this we are now starting
to appreciate that in many neurological
and neurodevelopmental disorders
we are dealing with specific detect
defects in each of these different
human brain cell types so understanding
how
different these different cell types are
from each other and how they do what
they do
is really critical to understanding
brain function and health
and different disorders
what our lab does is we use cutting-edge
genomics tools to study uh brain cell
types
the tools and the workflows that we
depend on heavily
involve a combination of the now almost
ubiquitous single cell rnac
technologies with the newly emerging
spatial genomic methods
so i assume that most of you are already
familiar with what
single cell rna sequencing can offer in
terms of identifying cell types in a
tissue
it is a wonderful and unbiased method
that allows you to take a very complex
tissue like a human brain
you perform a binding grind assay by
putting the tissue in a blender getting
a suspension of single cells
and then reading the transcriptome of
each cell when you do this
in an unbiased and molecular level you
can actually identify
all the different types and subtypes of
cells in the tissue
this is a wonderful piece of information
to get started studying your tissue of
interest
but what it misses out is actually the
spatial context of all these different
cell types
where are all these different single
cytosix subtypes in a tissue
what are their neighbors what happens to
them and patient samples and disease
so to answer these important questions
uh
sort of a new field has been emerging
over the past five to six years
uh a sort of a i think quick way to
describe it is spatial genomics
and so far it's been mainly based on
sort of two different
technological approaches the first
approach is spatially results sequencing
where different techniques aspire
to capture transcriptomes from thin
tissue sections in a positional manner
and read them out by sequencing as i'll
tell you in the next slide this is a
wonderful
method to get high throughput data but
it has certain limitations
as an alternative there has also been an
explosion in the number of different
imaging methods that can address this
question
and now there are a variety of
techniques out there that allow you to
multiplex
the measurements of dozens of different
rnas or proteins together
uh visualizing the expression of them in
different cell types and
special tissue context with all these
different methods
the workflow that we are trying to get
at is
summarized here single siren ac gets you
started in identifying which cell types
are
spatially resolved sequencing or
multiplex rna
imaging can actually place these cell
types in spatial locations in a tissue
and when you put all that information
together you can actually reconstruct
the cellular architecture of a tissue
with spatial resolution
so we are quite excited about a bunch of
different technologies that achieve this
and i'll do a little bit of pr before i
actually talk about the science
and to sort of answer these questions at
the
sanger institute in collaboration with
the european bioinformatics institute
they've actually started a high
throughput spatial genomics initiative
that will make great use of all the
methods that you see on this slide
to map different human organs as part of
our involvement in the human cell atlas
if i dig a little bit deeper into how
these different spatial genomic
technologies
uh work in this presentation i'll be
focusing mostly on methods that
measure the transcriptome with spatial
resolution hence
spatial transcriptomics from now on the
first method that allows you to
study transcriptomes in space is
basically spatially resolved rna
sequencing
there are multiple commercial or
experimental home brewed methods
available to do this such as museum or
slide seek
the idea here is that you have an array
where you can put a thin tissue section
on you end up capturing you know
all messenger rnas in your tissue
onto that array and you read out this
information
this positionally captured transcriptome
information that sequencing
these assays come at various spatial
resolutions
from dozens of cells to almost
subcellular resolution
but what they have in common is that
they actually give you multi-cell
spatial information the arrays
consist of these regular spatial grids
that do not really
respect the boundaries of each cell so
what you end up capturing at each array
location is basically signal from
multiple cell types
so that is a bit of a disadvantage for
spatial sequencing
but uh the advantages that it offers is
that it gives you transcription-wide
information
and it also offers you the high
throughput of sequencing
now the alternative to these methods has
been
mostly the different imaging
technologies
high multiplexed rna imaging gives you
exquisite
uh spatial resolution in a tissue uh the
image that you're seeing at the bottom
is four plex single molecule fish where
we have
marked different rnas and different cell
types
at near single molecule regulation hence
you can identify single cells in the
images and then you can quantify rna
expression within each cell
so you have the wonderful spatial
resolution here but
the drawbacks are that uh
first at the moment most methods do not
offer you transcripts of mite
information
you generally have to select a panel of
about a 50 to 100 genes
and go after that hence multiplexing
this kind of high multiplexed rna
imaging requires
very specialized cyclic microscopy
setups
and because of the multiple cycles of
imaging required the data throughput is
often low
the technology that i'll talk to you
today uh the nanostring called
transcriptional mount mountlessing in a
way
combines the strengths of both of these
spatially resolved sequencing
and imaging technologies uh it does
offer you
cellular resolution and throughout the
presentation i'll
explain to you exactly what that is and
how that is different from single side
resolution
it does use a pro panel against 18 000
genes
as rudy mentioned in his introduction
but that effectively provides you
transmitting wide information
it uses sequencing as a readout hence it
offers you high throughput
and finally and perhaps a massive
advantage for
nanostring profiling is that unlike
spatially resolved rna sequencing
methods
it's already optimized to work really
well on archival ffpe material which
constitutes most of the
tissue most of the patient drive tissues
so to jump right into what the
nanostring hole transcriptomicing which
i will abbreviate as wta and the rest of
the presentation is
rudy also gave you a great introduction
to what an interesting workflow is
the wta is seamlessly integrated into
the workflow
and the way it works is that
you start with a thin piece of tissue on
a standard microscope slides
this could be ff this is most often ffbe
but you could also imagine
doing fresh frozen or fixed frozen down
the line
you label this piece of tissue for a
limited set of imaging markers that
distinguish different cell types or
tissue regions
then you put on your wta nanostring
probes
which are basically in situ
hybridization probes against
18 000 genes covering the
majority of the human transcriptome now
these probes have a really special trick
up their sleeve
because in addition to their target
specific region that goes and binds to
the transcripts in the tissue
they actually have an oligonucleotide
based sequencing tag
at their tail the sequencing tag is
separated from the main pro body using
an
uv photo cleavable linker and what this
allows you to do
is to basically collect these tags
on the geomx dsp platform
so after we do and i forgot my
lovely little animations here after you
put your wta
probes you put the label slides on the
gmx dsp machine which first
images the imaging markers lets you
identify
where your tissue regions
and their region and cells of interest
are
after that uh you shine the photo
cleaving uv light
on areas that you identify either
manually or using image segmentation
as you saw in the previous slides this
photo
photocleaving
liberates the next generation sequencing
barcoded
probe tags these tags are collected
using the
little zipper which puts them in a 96
well plates and after this is done
for all the regions of interest which
i'll abbreviate
as rois from now on uh you take your
well
of barcodes you put this into the you
know
any kind of illumina sequencer and
that allows you to quantify the amount
of pro barcode
that is generated from each region and
uh for this presentation all the data
that we've told you about was generated
using the noaa c6000
s4 machines
so in our work we
in our early access work in
collaboration with
nanostring we decided to use this wta
method
to perform spatial transcriptomic
profiling of the developing human brain
and we did this because of two reasons
first as i told you at the beginning we
are interested in understanding cell
type diversity in the human brain
and the cell type the great diversity of
neurons and non-neuronal cells that you
see in the adult brain
it actually all goes back to the genetic
mechanisms that operate
in your brain in the womb so uh
what the cell types what different cell
types do
in the fetal brain has a lot to do with
how
different cell types are generated and
are maintained into the adulthood
second the fetal human brain
specifically the fetal human cerebral
cortex
has a wonderful spatial architecture of
different cell types that we can use
as a nice validation benchmark for wta
technology
the main spatial architectural principle
of this organ
is that it's split into two compartments
the first compartments as you can see in
the diagrams in the middle
is the germinal centers where different
populations of neural stem cells and
neural progenitors reside
in these germinal centers which sub
stratify into
zones such as the ventricular zone outer
subventricular zone intermediary zone
you have various different populations
of neural stem cells such as ventricular
or outer radial glia
and you also have transit amplifying
neural progenitors
that are generated from these which are
called the eyepiece and those are marked
in blue
while the radially are marked in green
and red
the development of the neocortex the
sustainable cortex
is quite complicated but it actually
follows a rather
sort of simple fundamental principle you
have your neural stem cells
in the germinal center they undergo
series of
cell divisions to proliferate and also
give rise to different shading neurons
and non-neuronal cells
these newly born neurons then actually
physically migrate out from the germinal
centers
into the differentiated parts of the
tissue
and this part of the tissue is called
the cortical plate which
is the basically the structure
that gives rise to the mature adult
brain
containing all the different
differentiated neurons and non-neuronal
cells in the future
so if you were to then look at the
different distribution of cell types in
the fetal cortex as a summary
you get your neural progenitors and
of different kinds in the germinal
centers you have newborn neurons in the
germinal centers
there you can see a physical migration
of differentiating cells out towards the
cortical plate
and in the cortical plate you have
different populations of differentiated
neurons
to complicate the picture a little bit
for you i'll today
today i'll also talk about uh sort of a
second population of neurons
uh which are called interneurons that
are involved in inhibitory gabaergic
transmission
these guys are actually not born in the
german centers of the cortex they're
actually not made
elsewhere in the cortex but to make
researchers lives more complicated
what they do is that they actually
migrate tangentially
into the germinal centers and the cortex
they enter it through
the sort of the deepest part that's
known as the ventricular zone
and from there they actually switch to
radial migration mode to populate the
cortical plates
now with working with nanostring
we decided to perform or design
wta experiments that can illustrate
the sort of the spatially orchestrated
migration and different shaded
of the fetal cortex and this was done
by a great collaboration uh with uh
my postdoc in my lab kenny roberts and
robin proff who works for data strange
and what we did here was actually
fundamentally quite simple experiment
we take a thin human brain tissue
section which is indicated in a panel b
we label this tissue section for
markers of all neural progenitors which
is shown in green
specific types of neural stem cells
which is shown in red as well as
intermediate transit amplifying
progenitors which are
derived from neural stem cells in blue
and if you were to look into the panel c
and d you can actually see the regions
of interest that we profile with
nanostring
in d you can see that across the entire
sort of cortical depth uh going from the
germinal centers to the cortical plate
we have
profiled segmental areas that cover
different zones and different cell types
the first question we had is that uh
this is supposed to be the whole
transcription assay so are we actually
measuring
the expression of many many genes in
this assay and the answer
hope uh successfully uh was yes
so in this plot what you're seeing is a
sort of a
gross combination of all the data that
we have collected what you're seeing
here is the number of genes detected
in rois that contain anywhere from you
know five to
two thousand nuclei across the cortex
and as you can see
uh on an average of 1200 nuclei that we
profile in each roi
we are detecting the expression of at
least 6 000 genes so
that effectively offers you
transformational light information
seeing this you could actually you might
ask me
what the sensitivity the lower
sensitivity of nanostring is
you know in these rois we have thousands
of cells
but can we actually go down to really
small numbers of cells
and the answer that so far is yes to go
about
this what we did was focus on the
profiling of one of these specific brain
regions
in the diagram in the middle it's boxed
in with the
red box the ventricular zone
which primarily consists of one cell
type
called ventral radioglia in green in
the four different boxes lettered a to d
in the image you can see that we have
profiled with wta
different sizes or different numbers of
nuclei in a we have something about
only five nuclei identified by image
analysis
and in d we have about a hundred nuclei
and on the plot about
you can see that indeed even with just
five cells we can detect the expression
of about 4
000 genes and as we go up from you know
60 to 100 genes we actually start to
increase
the detection rate to what we see in
large numbers of nuclei on top of this
the genes that we are seeing here are
not coming from
transcriptional or technical noise or
anything if you were to
look into existing single significant
data sets of the brain
and pull out genes that are specific to
ventricular radioglia
you can see that across each area we can
identify the expression of several
hundred of these genes
suggesting that we can indeed detect
transcripton-wide information
from as little as five cells
the results that we get with this are
highly reproducible both technically and
biologically
what you're seeing here now is just the
data that we have generated from the
cortical
differentiated plates and what you're
seeing is
data from two tissue sections which are
coming from the same brain they are
consecutive to each other on different
slides
hence they can be treated as technical
replicates
and as you can see the expression
profile that we get from these two
tissue sections these two technical
replicates
highly correlate with each other on top
of this
when we compare the cortical plate from
different cases so now we are comparing
what we measure in the cortical plate
from brain donor one
to what we get in brain donor two we
also see high technical reproducibility
suggesting that the results of the wta
assay are highly consistent
now the wta assay is pro binding based
hence you expect to see a certain amount
of
background binding because having 1 5 or
20 probes
is not going to give you 100 specific
detection of your target transcripts
so to go about identifying what this
background is
and subtracting it from the wta data
a graduate student in our lab alexander
iva zivadis
built a wonderful tool box that we
called in c2 style sequencing or
in situ cell isc tools
in building this he was influenced by
new
probabilistic generative models
developed for single cell data analysis
by neil yosef as indicated in the cited
publication
and simply what this model does
is that it looks at your wta data it
identifies what the real signal is
which we we call as the biological
signal and it also identifies what the
technical noise is
the technical noise comes from both the
sampling noise or wta
but it also comes from this non-specific
binding of the probes
and uh while you know we identify this
using modeling
we actually based uh this model
on experimental measurements of negative
control probes
that are included in the wta assay
so without going any further into how
this model works i'll actually show you
how it performs so the first thing is a
control
what we have here on the left are
plots showing the expression of a very
well-known neuronal marker
stmn2 across different regions of
interest across cortical depth
so to orient you with these plots every
dot that you're seeing on there
is the expression in one region of
interest the x-axis corresponds to the
sort of cortical depth position of the
region of interest so they go
from left the germinal zone ventricular
zone
to the right the cortical plate where
all the differentiated neurons are
and then on the y-axis you can actually
see the sort of normalized expression
levels
the blue and the red dots that you're
seeing there are
the blue is the raw data which is
uncorrected and the red
is the background corrected data which
is estimated by our model
and uh the reason that we started with
stmn2 here is that
it is actually a sort of a positive
control for our assay we know that
is a really highly expressed gene that
should be detected in neurons
and we would expect that if our model is
working correctly it should not
take away the expression of this and it
should sort of accept
the expression of stmm2 as a
true gene and this is precisely what it
does as you can see the blue and the red
dots are not that different from each
other
and furthermore we can actually validate
this on the same tissue material using
fluorescent
seizure hybridization so what you're
seeing on the right is actually rna
scope single molecule fish against this
gene
which indeed across the cortical depth
shows
high signal in the cortical plates
so this is a good gene a bad gene is
dlx1
so this is a gene that is a known marker
of
interneurons as i said at the beginning
interneurons
are uh most abundantly found
in the journal centers in the
ventricular zone at this point
so the real signal that you expect to
see for this gene
is mainly based there and there will
also be actually like a little bump in
the cortical plate because you already
have interneurons moving in there
so when you look at the raw wta data you
indeed see a little bump in the journal
centers but as you can see
in the mid cortex you see tons of
signals so that would be depths
0.2 to 0.8 and you can see that you know
the blue dots give you sort of signal at
200 expression levels the
we were very happy to see that the isc
model performed successfully here
in red you can see the corrected counts
and while
i hope you can appreciate that we have
maintained the enrichment
of the lx1 expression in the ventricular
zone and the low cortical depth
we have actually successfully removed
all the backgrounds you know that we
expect to see in the mid cortex
and we can actually validate this using
nc2 hybridization so on the right you
now see an rna scope some fish
against dlx1 you see enriched expression
of this gene
in the ventricular zone which is
indicated with the yellow arrow with a
high mag on the
rightmost panel and elsewhere in the
cortex you actually do not see a lot of
expression
and that suggests that our background
collection model is working correctly
so with that i can actually jump right
to the
interesting stuff uh since we know
that uh the wta assay gives you
transcription right information and we
can crank the background
information let's actually look at what
the spatial expression profiles look
like
the first question we asked is that the
known spatial expression of different
cell types neuroprogenitors in the
general centers
and differentiating neurons in the
cortical plates does it hold up
and the great answer to this is yes as
you can see on the plot
on the left on the right sorry uh
what we have is the expression of known
cell type markers across cortical depth
and i hope you can appreciate that as
boxed and read
we see highly enriched expression of
neural stem cell and neural progenitor
markers in the
germinal centers of the ventricular zone
and
conversely we see that the expression of
different types of neurons
maturing excitatory uh or you know
already mature excited or deep layer
neurons is enriched
in the in the cortical plate suggesting
that we can
actually successfully visualize spatial
gene expression patterns using this
technology
now um you know we did the spatial
sulfide marker mapping largely as a
validation to see if we would get the
known
celtic distribution but after that we
wanted to do some fun stuff with it
and the first thing we did was that we
wanted to see if the expression of genes
that have been genetically linked to
different
neurodevelopmental disorders or things
like brain size
whether we could detect that they were
spatially enriched in different parts of
the cortex
and in doing this we were greatly
influenced by a study which did lots and
lots of volcanic speech
of different human brain regions to
suggest that the expression of about 100
or so genes
that are genetically linked to autism
are actually strongly in
linked or enriched in deep cortical
layers in the cortical plates
and you're really happy to see that when
we
compared the expression of these genes
linked to autism with other disorders
as well as the old genesis of control we
could indeed validate
that the expression of these autism
genes were
enriched in the deep cortical plate
compared to other parts of the brain
so uh what this shows you that uh
what this shows you i think is that
while the wta assay
can nicely illustrate where the
expression patterns of different cell
type markers are
it can also give you information on
disease-related gene expression
so um the experiments that i showed you
so far
we're doing bulk region of interest
profiling in each region of interest we
had hundreds of you know different
nuclei hundreds of different cell types
and as i showed in the beginning we're
actually quite interested in taking this
data
and we're interested in how putting this
together with cell type specific
information with single cell rna-seq
and enrich the level of biological
information we get from it
and to do this we actually adapted a
workflow a computational workflow
that you call style to location that was
recently developed by a graduate student
in my lab we call it clash chemnico
as part of a great collaboration with
ollie stegel
who is based on amble in germany and the
idea here is that you can
from the same piece of tissue you
generate both spatial transcriptomics
data
that consists of many cell types in each
location but on top of it you have your
single style or single nuclei reference
salto location computationally puts
these two together
to locate the reference cell types from
the single cell data sets
on the spatial transcriptomic data and
what that achieves
is it allows you to in one go at really
high throughput
locate the spatial position of every
single cell type
in your tissue of interest
so to go about doing this in the human
brain uh we
turned our attention to a sort of
previously published single cell
transcriptomic atlas
of the human cortex this wonderful paper
from the gesturing lab
did exactly this at a sort of a
gestational age that matches what we did
in our single
in our wta profiling in their wonderful
study you can see that's
in the plots in panel b that they have
actually identified
over 20 different major cell types that
make up the cortex
covering both the known subtypes of
neural progenitors from the germinal
centers
as well as different types of neurons
from the cortical plates
our idea in our workflow is that we take
this
dissociative single thyronyx catalyst
that was published
we integrate we take each one of these
cell types and then we map
their locations in our geomx wta data
across the cortical depth
and what this allows you to do then is
across each of our regions of interest
across cortical depth from the germinal
center so the cortical plate
we can identify both the proportions
and the densities of each cell type in
these data sets
so some controls before we actually dive
deep into this uh what you're seeing now
is
uh cell to location mapping results of
one subtypes
it's the outer radioglia which is the
neural stem cell that is concentrated in
this region called
osvz and if you are if you look at
our cell to location results you can see
that indeed we have successfully
mapped this cell type specifically
to the uh outer sub-ventricular zone in
the general center
a quick technical note that we'll make
here is that uh
the soft location version that we used
here
was actually modified was adapted to
work best with wta data
if we were to take the versions of cell
to location
that are designed or catered for other
technologies such as vision
we still get good sort of mapping of
radioglio to the outer subventricular
zone
but we actually start seeing sort of
background mapping to other brain
regions
such as the cortical plate which is sort
of boxed in
uh with the dashed uh diagram on the
second
so it is actually important if you're
using these
sort of self-location-like integration
tools it's important to use the right
kind of tool
that is adapted to your technology
so i'll just jump you i'll just walk you
quickly now
through our cell type mapping results in
the fetal cortex
so what you're seeing here now is a cell
density map of each of the 17 cell types
uh
identified in the single crnaseq data
across our wta data sets
as i did previously the x-axis shows you
the
sort of the spatial position of
each segmental region of interest across
cortical depth
from right to from left to right it's
going as general center the cortical
plate
and the size of the different dots for
each cell type
show you actually their predicted
density and
the output that we're talking about here
is actually compared
to a almost a manual count of cells in
that region of interest
so when we say that we think that there
are 3
thousand cells of one cell type a region
of interest we actually base that
both on self-location mapping as well as
the total number of nuclei identified
there
based on imaging so the
results of this mapping were largely a
success we were really delighted to see
that both the neural progenitors and
differentiating neurons were
successfully mapped to where they are
supposed to be
the kind of the two highlights that i'd
like to present you today
is that this mapping is really sensitive
enough to actually call
different subtypes so if we were now to
focus on
neural stem cells different types of
neural stem cells that are
located in the ventricular zone versus
the outer subventricular zone which are
the green and the red cells diagram in
the top
you actually see that sulfur location
predicts them to be in spatially
different areas of the terminal centers
in a similar manner when we look at the
spatial positions of neurons across
different steps of their differentiation
we see this really wonderful spatial
gradient we see that newborn neurons
identified as xn are located in the
germinal centers
the migrating neurons are sort of found
transiting between the adrenal centers
and the cortical plate
and then the differentiated neurons
which are indicated as mu and dp1
are nicely located in a cortical plate
suggesting that the cell type mapping
has the sensitivity to be able
to distinguish the special positions of
finely related
fine stages of neural differentiation
finally the advantage of doing
uh something like the wta assay in a way
i think the
sort of one of the major advantages over
other methods is that it's high
throughput
uh the data that i showed you before uh
or
showed you so far was generated at one
age during fetal development that's 19
post-conception weeks
with the throughput of the wta assay we
could easily start looking at
uh tissue from donors from other
other ages in fetal development and here
now what you're seeing is the cell type
mapping comparing 14
to 19 post conception weeks and when you
look at these maps there's really a
huge wealth of information that you can
identify for example between 14 and 19
weeks
you can sort of see that's both
qualitatively and quantitatively
we get this big increase in the number
of interneurons that
are colonizing the ventricular zone the
cortex
and at this time period we also see a
big increase
in the number of neurons excitatory
neurons that are accumulating in the
cortical plate
showing you that we can actually get uh
really nice comparative information
using this methodology
finally what i'll close by is uh
the sort of uh the next level version of
wa technology
uh so far i told you about doing the
bulk wta
bulk region profiling and the single
slot deconvolution
but as i said at the beginning what the
wta tech does
is that's using imaging and sensitive
you know region restricted photocleavage
it allows you to actually perform cell
type specific wa profiling
and in this experiment what we did is
that we picked regions of interest that
were quite similar
to what we processed for our bulk roi
experiments so the balkan experiments
are indicated as
white boxes on the image on the left
and then the yellow boxes with the green
boxes of the asterix
are the adjacent regions where we did
our segmentation
so within each region what we achieved
to do in this
experiment was use image segmentation to
identify different cell populations
based on their markers and profile them
so in red we have neural stem cells that
are distinguished by the expression of
opex
in dark blue we have eoms positive
intermediate progenitors
so you know these two populations are
identified by segmentation of the image
markers and then they can be
photocleaved distinctly
with high spatial resolution to give you
their wta
sequencing tags and after we do this we
also do a couple control things so
we also identify the reference rings so
buffer zones around each cell type
allowing us to measure the diffusion of
the rna signal
and after we were done collecting our
neural stem cell and ip
regions of interest and reference things
we also collected everything else which
is the residual
and from the gecko you can see that uh
this kind of approach is successful
the first piece of data that you're
seeing here is the number of genes that
we detect
in each segmented area and you can see
that for both intermediate progenitors
and neural stem cells red and blue
we can identify almost something like
four to six thousand genes for each cell
population within each roi
giving us that transcription wide
profiling information
now the litmus test of knowing whether
cell type specific profiling worked
is comparing the expression profiles wta
expression profiles
of these two different populations and
when we do that in red and blue
we indeed observe that the right kind of
markers are enriched between them
and furthermore what we can do is that's
we
can engage our probabilistic generative
model that we used for background
correction earlier
and we could actually increase the
number of genes that we identify here so
i think at the moment we are actually up
to almost like a thousand genes that we
can distinguish
between these intermediate progenitor
and neural stem cell
uh cell areas of interest
and many of these genes we're happy to
see include known cell type markers of
ips or neural stem cells
we can also see since we are doing
transcription-wide information we can
also actually compare
the data that we are generating here to
single-sirenix-c
so what you're seeing here now on the
plot on the left
is the expression of uh the wta profile
of all genes that we could detect an
intermediate progenitors
marked in red on the y-axis and then on
the x-axis
is the mean expression profiling of the
matching cell type clusters
from the singles rnac data set that we
showed before as you can see the
correlation here is not perfect but
there's definitely a strong relationship
what you get from wta and singles rna
seq suggesting that the information that
you're gathering here
with some type specific profiling is
indeed accurate
so uh i went a little bit over time so i
hope that was all right with everyone uh
what i'll do is i'll just sort of walk
you through the conclusions
very quickly so hopefully today i
convince you that the wta assay can be
used on ffpe tissues
so extract gene expression with spatial
resolution
from bulk regions as well as cell types
of interest
i presented to you a background
collection model which
improves what we get out of nano string
data and it correctly estimates the
extent of non-specific binding for each
wta probe
the application that we presented to you
today on human fetal brains
i think it is actually the first
validation of genetic data that autism
genes are enriched in a specific part of
the developing brain
uh using an adapted version of our
spatial transcriptomic integration model
we have actually found novel
localizations of multiple cell types
which i could not cover
due to the time limitations but
i think what i showed you today
illustrates that
we can map the spatial locations of many
cell types and high throughput
using both wta and single cell
technologies
and finally using the cell type specific
profiling that i had
and at the end of the presentation we
can even extract
cell type specific information from wta
profiling
so with that i'll quickly acknowledge
the people who did the work kenny great
postdoc who
worked on the web lab site alexander and
italy are the graduate students who
worked on data analysis
robin trump from nanostring was
instrumental in all of these experiments
close by one pr
piece as i said we are doing spatial
genomic stuff
at high throughput at sanger and ebi and
we are recruiting people so if you're
interested please get in touch
and with that i'll uh hand this over to
our moderator
and take questions
and thank you dr byrochtar and dr
zajok and dr van eisten for that
informative presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar
and if you have any questions you want
to ask please do so now
just click on that ask a question box
located on the far
left of your screen we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for
so let's get started we have quite a few
questions
already coming in our first question
and this is directed to you um rudy
could you elaborate
more on the barcode design are they
umi based random hexamers or
how many targets do they cover
uh well thanks for that question that's
uh well it's an obvious
question that comes up in the setting uh
yes it's uni based
so we use umis to make sure we sequence
uh single molecules
um so the umi is 14 bases in length
and the actual target specific part of
the barcode is
as 12 bases in length so
how many targets do they cover so having
12 bases for the target specific part
well i just did the calculation very
quickly that gives you a theoretically
16 million possibilities
but since omar is just describing
already we're doing whole transcriptome
covering over 18 000
genes so that's as many targets that we
can cover we can cover the whole
transcript too
yes thanks for the question
thank you so much and omar this question
is for you can the wta
assay offer single cell resolution
we haven't tested this explicitly but we
think so so i showed data
where uh the wta assay offers you five
cell resolution
where we can already identify the
expression of
four thousand genes and five cells um
the geo max dsp paper that came out
earlier this year in nature biotech i
think showed that
you can measure and rudy can correct me
here uh i think it showed that you can
measure
protein expression at single slot
resolution but it shied a little bit
away from rna
i think based on what we saw for five
cells i think a single cell
is most likely in the sort of
reach of wta assay the questions will be
how consistent will be the single cell
readings uh
and from different tissues how they
would scale to each other but it's
definitely something worth trying
thank you very much and i want to thank
our audience members for these great
questions coming in
we actually have time for one more
question you mentioned that
cell type specific wta
and single cell rna sequence
correlate but not perfectly how could
this correlation
be improved that's a great question
so um i think there are sort of couple
different dimensions there
so the first dimension is that uh in our
experiments we actually have like a
while you know the single scientific and
wta data set
match roughly in terms of like what age
of fetal brain development we're looking
at
they're actually from different donors
and generated in completely different
instances
so if we actually generated those data
sets from the same
donor you'd probably have more
correlation but i think the more sort of
important underlying question is that it
is
most likely not statistically correct
to try to correlate what you get from
single scientific directly to wta
and the reason for that is that there's
a platform specific effect where
both the sensitivity and other sort of
under the hood bits of w3a and single
science secret difference
and to be able to correlate those two
methods to each other what you need to
do is use integration tools like
self-location
and the last bit is that's you know the
cell type specific profiling that we did
can certainly be improved
we did sort of like as a really simple
image segmentation where we took
all the signal including whole cells
parts of cells which is probably
contaminated by other cell types to some
extent
moving forward you can actually do more
complex and stringent
cellular segmentation from image data
and that can actually
improve possibly what you get from
single-sided correlation
gentlemen i want to thank you so much
for your presentations today
awesome excellent thank you so much i
also want to thank our audience for
joining us today and for their
interesting questions
and questions we did not have time for
today and those submitted
during the on-demand period will be
addressed by our speakers via the
contact information
you provided at the time of registration
again
thank you again gentlemen for your
presentations and for your important
research
and i want to thank lab roots and our
sponsors illumina
and now string technologies for
underwriting today's educational webcast
you can view this webinar on demand and
labyrinths will alert you via email
when it's available for replay please
join us in the
upcoming virtual event advancing science
in spatial biology conference you won't
want to miss
this exciting event that's all for now
until next time
stay safe take care bye